a very odd story surfacing the last 24
hours
from American electronic music artist
Moby who wrote a Facebook post on Monday
saying that he spent the weekend talking
to friends who work in DC and that he
can accurately make some extraordinarily
damning claims about the Trump
administration will put up
Moby's post from facebook here where he
talks about having spoken to Washington
insiders who told him that what is in
the Donald Trump Russia blackmail
dossier is not even close to the most
nefarious thing that Donald Trump is
currently being blackmailed for and Mobe
says in this post that we're looking at
that his source has told him that Trump
is in collusion with the Russian
government and has been since day one he
said that the GOP and the Koch brothers
have plans to get rid of Trump that
their intelligence agencies around the
world working to present information
that will lead to high-level firings and
ultimately impeachment of Trump and he
said that the u.s. is planning to go to
war with Iran and already moving naval
naval fleets to Iran's coast and Moby
added in this post I'm writing these
things so that when and if these things
happen there will be a public record
beforehand these are truly baffling and
horrifying times as we have an
incompetent president who is essentially
owned by a foreign power now in response
to the skepticism that surface right
after Moby did the Facebook post he then
went on to a different social media
platform Twitter and tweeted about the
skepticism where he said quote and I'll
put this up on the screen for you most
of the info I referenced is of public
record or will be relatively soon also
hoping Trump Bannen Iran war plans are
thwarted so much of this is definitely
not public record as of today Trump is
being blackmailed for worse than what's
in the dossier that's not public record
today there are world intelligence
agencies planning to release information
on Trump that's not part of the public
record but again Moby said or will be
soon
Trump planning a war with Iran I mean we
kind of have a sense of that it does
seem that that's
something that the groundwork is being
laid for uh that the Republican Party is
planning to oust Trump not public record
but we are increasingly suspecting that
there's a contingent within the
Republican Party that's more and more
displeased with Donald Trump and then
Trump overtly colluding with the Russian
government well this one we basically
know everything but that that they were
in touch that Russia hack the election
to help Trump the one thing that hasn't
yet been proven is that there was actual
collusion I would love for Moby to give
us more information or some of that
proof if he has it I don't know that he
does this reminds me of after the Access
Hollywood Billy Bush tapes came out
where Donald Trump talked about how he
grabs women yeah
people started to put the pressure on
Mark Burnett who is the executive
producer on The Apprentice you got to
release some of the stuff that he had on
Trump the dirt that he had and that
never actually came into fruition those
were just words I mean these are actions
here and if any one of those is
legitimate that's an impeachable offense
so there's a ton of speculation about
what's going on with Mobe right but Modi
could have just made this up completely
out of thin air I don't think that's
likely I don't know but I get the sense
that he's not just going to say hey I'm
gonna go on Facebook and just make stuff
up wholesale Moby could be
misinterpreting what he was told and
maybe getting a different impression of
what it is it's also possible that the
people Moby spoke to and I believe Moby
spoke to people it's just a question of
do those people actually know Moby
sources themselves could have been
either wrong misinformed or exaggerating
and also Moby could just be actually
write about some of this stuff and wrong
about other stuff but it's also possible
Moby is 100% right which would be
without a doubt the biggest scandal of
American politics in the last I don't
know how many years I mean if the
allegations from Moby are 100% correct
this goes above and beyond what any of
us have suspected over the last several
months yeah it's one of those things you
want to cover from the very beginning
because if more information does go out
then you can kind of go back to the
source of all of this which was Moby
post but most of these claims are what I
would certainly call extraordinary
claims not in the colloquial sense but
sort of the idea that extraordinary
claims
quire extraordinary evidence I know not
everybody likes that phrase but the sort
of point I'm getting at is if Moby is
making these claims which are not proven
currently then we need to see evidence
of the claims may be claiming alone is
not actual evidence and until we get
that we just have to suspend judgment
funny little note Moby was reportedly
asked to perform at Donald Trump's
inaugural ball imagine if he's actually
the guy who previews what are
blockbusters of information upcoming and
he happened to have been invited to
perform for Donald Trump well I think
just about everyone was asked to perform
at Donald Trump's inauguration and they
had to settle in the Mormon Tabernacle
Choir
I like that Mormon tavarov antastic
their rendition of Ozzy Osbourne songs
is like nothing I've ever seen before
discuss this or any other stories of
interest on our profession discussion
for us david pakman.com slash read it we
crack ourselves up sometimes let's take
a break part two of my interview with
Peter Boghossian coming up next today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in too I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS